all right hi everyone my name is brian
mcwilliams i'm part of the qaqc team
here at bethel laboratories and
fortified sciences
and i'm going to be talking to you today
about antibody validation why we do it
how we do it and some of the specific
implications for that validation in the
immuno oncology space
i'm going to actually start today by
telling a little story about a protein
called f-o-r
and f-o-r is a member of the jack stat
signaling cascade and it was originally
discovered early in the 90s and then in
the 2000s it was implicated in cancer
and that implication was mediated
primarily by an antibody called c20
and the western blot in the bottom left
hand corner of this slide you can see
that the band indicated with the red
arrow was thought to be fo r and these
are in multiple different cell lines
multiple different cancer cell lines
and that increase in expression
was thought to have potential
implications in cancer and so they
proceeded into clinical studies
only to find out that c20 was in fact
not binding for at all but was in fact
binding a heat shock protein known as
hsp 70 which had nothing at all to do
with cancer
so obviously
some front end work trying to validate
that antibody and really get a good feel
for what it was doing making sure it was
binding to the right target protein had
a lot of downstream implications and a
lot of loss both in time and in some of
the financial aspects as well
so the obvious question there is how
much money could you potentially lost
were a similar mistake made today
this image here is from 2014 and goes
through a few different therapeutic
areas and some of the costs associated
with
clinical studies in those areas and you
can see
biology field that i've got highlighted
um a phase one through phase three study
totals off at almost 40 million dollars
total and as you move into fda review in
phase four you're looking at upwards of
80 million dollars
potential patient costs with those
studies through phase 3 comes up to
almost 42 000 so obviously
front end mistakes and a lack of
validation could potentially result in
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
losses for either the biotech companies
working through these labs working
through these licensing agencies working
through these and for patients as well
and this is particularly interesting in
the i o space
because as you can see here we've got a
comparison
of io research and io therapeutic and io
clinical research
and how that's changed some between the
years 2017 and 2020 and you can see a
handful of different therapy types over
on on the left and you'll notice for
each therapy type we're seeing just
massive growth even between the years
2017 and 2020 it's estimated to be just
over 230 percent growth just over this
three-year period so combining some of
the the raw numbers that you're seeing
here and some of the dollar amounts that
you saw on that previous slide you can
only imagine some of the potential
dollars that are at risk by uh
generating some of these studies and
then using reagents that have not been
validated correctly
so that kind of begs the question like
what what is antibody validation what do
we mean by that
the fda generally defines validation as
the process of demonstrating through the
use of specific laboratory
investigations that the performance
characteristics of an analytical method
are suitable for its intended analytical
use
so that's a very broad statement i know
within the antibody world what you're
really looking at there is to show that
the antibodies
that you're utilizing are both
reproducible and they're specific
and that last statement there that i
thought underlined about it being for
its intended analytical use
i think really captures a lot of what
antibody validation is about because
not only are you trying to ensure that
your antibody is
reproducible and is specific for what
you're trying to do
it's also really important that the
use of that antibody is consistent and
so whatever you're validating it for and
what you're validating it to use it for
is pretty consistent and very
reproducible day to
day it's also important to keep in mind
that there
can in some circumstances be a
difference between a validated antibody
and a useful antibody
now i've i've got here a very uh
clear
clear looking illustration of what a
validated antibody may look like this is
an antibody against the target protein
hr on the far left and we see a very
nice clean single band
and then as we move from left to right
our western blocks are getting a little
bit uglier so this this cap one antibody
here in the middle we're seeing a very
clear and obvious cap one western blot
with a nice clean band but we're also
seeing some off target binding as well
and then as we move left to right we're
seeing this mll1 antibody western blot
where the plot looks a lot worse we're
seeing a significant amount of off
target binding but we're still able to
see this this band and so it becomes
really important to be able to define
what is validated what is useful is
there a difference in those two things
and what are the implications of those
potential differences
antibody validation also can have some
very unique challenges and some unique
circumstances that you've got to be able
to kind of work through and really
understand the context of the biology of
your target protein
so one of these particular challenges is
the molecular weight pitfall
and by that i mean
when you go into a western blot and
something where you can very easily
assess molecular weight there are
obviously a lot of resources a bit
available for you to be able to predict
the molecular weight of that protein
now when the band your antibody is
binding to migrates at a different
molecular weight you're left to answer
the question what is this antibody on
target here on the left i've got zbtb5
and this predicted molecular weights
about 75 kd we see it here migrating in
about 100 kd
on the right we've got the cap 1 protein
again migrating pretty close to 100 kd
it's predicted weight is closer to 88 kd
so you're sort of left to try and figure
out and understand hey is this antibody
on target why do i think this antibody
is on target and if it is on target how
do i prove that that is on target
independent of just this molecular
weight prediction
something else that can be particularly
tricky with antibodies in particular is
uh
sort of falsely associating the
localization of antibody derived signal
on a tissue sample so here we've got a
non-hodgkin's b-cell lymphoma kidney
tissue
that we've stained with an anti-eom's
antibody
and we know the eoms is nuclear and
we're seeing very clear nuclear staining
on this slide
now if this antibody were binding
something off target that also happened
to be a nuclear protein
you would have no way of differentiating
that eom's mediated signal from this
off-target binding so again you're left
to answer some questions how do you know
that what you're seeing is on target and
if it is on target how do you prove that
to someone
one other potential problem is when
you're seeing multiple bands showing up
in a single lane oftentimes these can be
associated with different isoforms or
even tissue or cell lines specific
isoforms or just some sort of
post-translational modification of
phosphorylation or
glycosylation event so
in those scenarios like for example here
we're blotting with this anti-gata3
antibody we're seeing two very distinct
bands in mcs7 cells compared to one
distinct band and a jerk at t cell
western blot
and you're left with some questions here
how do i know what that second band is
is it on target is it off target and if
it is on target how do i prove that that
is in fact on target
so this can create problems for both
customers and for manufacturers and
distributors of antibodies because
nobody wants to sell you something
that's no good and obviously nobody
wants to buy a product that's not
working well either
and so there's sort of a symbiotic
relationship that can be
really really helpful as you're working
through kind of characterizing and
validating these in your own labs
from the manufacturer perspective it's
really important for us to be able to
clearly communicate what we're doing why
we're doing it and be able to talk to
you in a way that's relevant to the work
that you're doing
um oftentimes we'll do that through the
provision of experimental results
experimental details we've got a large
body of data typically that's supporting
a lot of these products and when we're
able to provide those to you as a
mechanism for you to better understand
your results that can really help us in
both directions
it's also important that the
manufacturers work hard to define what
that analytical use actually is
oftentimes you'll see antibodies
marketed for western blot for ihc for
icc for ip
make sure that there's data that is
supporting those
analytical uses if the manufacturer
can't get it to work but they're saying
that it can work that's usually a pretty
good red flag for me that something's
maybe not right or that that thing
hasn't been validated properly
i think i've alluded to this already but
it's really helpful for us to be able or
for manufacturers to be able to show as
much data as possible
get as much information out there as you
can because the more information the
customer ultimately has the better off
they're going to be in trying to figure
out how to adapt and utilize that
product for what it is that they're
doing and if and when a customer does
reach back out to that manufacturer make
sure that there's more of a
collaborative conversation there and a
back and forth to trying to figure out
what's going on and don't turn it into
just a
money back return whatever it is you
know getting that product to work well
is ultimately the goal for both sides um
as the customer
you need to receive an antibody and be
prepared to optimize
the product for whatever it is that
you're doing oftentimes you're going to
receive a product that says hey we
recommend this in a range let's say from
a one to two thousand dilution of one to
ten thousand don't always assume that
one side or the other is going to work
best for you be prepared to go ahead and
validate that product make sure that
it's doing what you expect it to do
and then prepare for subsequent
purchases of that same product to behave
in a very similar way
and also going into it make sure that
you have a very clear understanding of
what it is that you need
don't buy a product for a western blot
when you don't need it to western blot
or for an ihc when you don't want it to
isc make sure that what you're
purchasing it for that's what it's
designed to do
obviously you want to make sure that the
data that is being generated by the
manufacturer supports the type of work
that you want it to do
check and see if there's citations where
other researchers have used that product
for what it is that you're trying to do
and if you continue to struggle or if
you just have some questions on the
front end don't hesitate to reach out to
tech support it's often times that these
these tech support individuals are
scientists who know really well what it
is that you're trying to do and can help
you sort of adapt and optimize your
conditions to better suit those those
particular products
um
but still this does present a very large
challenge and it's something that can be
very fluid within the antibody world
just kind of at large
in 2016 and 2017 a group of researchers
that ultimately became known as the
international working group for antibody
validation published a couple of
articles
where they were trying to
sort of structure and organize the
validation of antibodies and sort of
standardize this across
all these different types of products
and what they ultimately proposed was a
series of what they call pillars
that should sort of support the research
utilizing all these products and these
five pillars i've got listed over here
on the right
these pillars included what they call
orthogonal strategies independent
antibody strategies genetic strategies
recombinant expression strategies and
capture mass spec strategies
um
we will talk about each of these in
depth here in just a few slides but i
did want to kind of talk on a more 10
000 foot level before we moved into that
degree of depth
you'll notice sort of in the antibody
manufacturing community that we begin to
adapt some of this language
and you'll see
products and landing pages that are
starting to allude to and refer to and
sort of illustrate
how these pillars are being used we've
got a belthole fortis landing page here
on the left biotechni rnd cst in the
bottom right and these are all sort of
versions of this antibody pillar
validation system that really sort of
fits in well with what these these
companies do
[Music]
historically and then are now being
adapted to help better validate and
better inform the customers who are
actually purchasing these products
um
what's really interesting and really
kind of cool about these these pillars
is that they have a what i would
describe as an additive effect to a
certain degree so
any one of these pillars
by itself doesn't always have a ton of
value for example if you've got
a mass spec and you've got a western
blot and they look like they should
that's a good piece of data that by
itself you could kind of make some
arguments to poke some holes in that but
when you start building you know two or
three of these pillars into sort of an
overall validation strategy
the additive effects of multiple pillars
can really do a lot more to support the
validation of a given product
now to a point that's true when you
start getting them above three and you
start getting into like four and five
pillars it starts to become a little bit
redundant and value gain by performing
some of those other pillar validations
you're really not learning a lot more
than what you already knew
um
it's also true that not every data set
is going to contribute equally to your
validation process so for example cap
one here in the top left you're seeing a
very ubiquitous expression pattern
through all these different cell lines
you don't really know if that's on
target or off target it could very
easily be an off target protein that
just happens to express in every cell
line you don't really know you don't
really have any way to prove it
if you know that that kaplan antibody
has been validated that western blot
creates some extra value for you so this
validation process isn't so much for you
to learn that you can use it or i guess
the better way to say that would be
validation teaches you that you can use
something the application data and some
of these
how to use something
it's also important to know that if
someone is to validate an antibody that
doesn't necessarily make it useful for
your work it just makes it useful for
theirs and so
it's important to remember that a
manufacturer validation process should
not replace
your validation process in your lab in
your hands in your conditions in your
cell culture conditions there's a lot of
novelty and a lot of variables that can
really play into what's happening in
your lab that are going to be different
and independent and unique from how that
that product is validated by the
manufacturer
so
from the
bethel fortis perspective we've sort of
adapted a little bit of a different
approach to these pillars so you'll
notice that the the top four pillars
were actually the same but we modified
the capture mass spec pillar because we
don't have a lot of mass spec capacity
here at bethel furnace
so we replaced that capture mass spec
with what we call a complementary assay
and a biological strategies um and we're
going to talk through those along with
the other six uh starting with this next
level
so the first pillar that we're going to
be discussing is what we refer to as the
independent antibodies pillar
and this is basically defined as using
two or more independent antibodies to
generate similar results
and it's important to keep in mind that
these antibodies need to be raised
against different epitopes of that
target protein
now historically at bethel we've used
what we refer to as a reciprocal ip
where we do in fact use two different
antibodies that were raised against two
different epitopes we will do
immunoprecipitation pull downs with both
of those antibodies and then blot with
one of them
and in a situation like the one we have
in the bottom left hand corner here with
ahr
if both antibodies are able to pull down
the same target protein we consider that
to be a very strong argument for that
binding our target protein and it does
fulfill the independent antibodies
pillar as it was two different
antibodies being used to generate the
same result
over here on the right this is a gata3
stain of a
tissue and we'll notice that these are
cereal sections and these two antibodies
are staining an extraordinarily similar
pattern in in both slides and so you
would say here that that that that data
is the same
and that those two antibodies are
performing the same and are binding to
the same target protein thus fulfilling
this pillar
the next pillar is the complementary
assays pillar and this is the other half
of the reciprocal ip where we have two
or more antibody dependent techniques
that are generating similar results so
with the reciprocal ip you've got an
immune precipitation and the western
blot of that ip that are gener
generating similar results this can also
include other scenarios like the one
that i've got illustrated at the bottom
of this slide here
where we've got the same antibody
binding well in a western blot this is a
sox10 antibody binding is sox10 and an
skml28
cell line
and you can see on the right here this
is an icc image of antibody staining
skml28 cells in culture we're getting
very strong signal and strong specific
signal on both of these we would say
that this did
in fact fulfill the complementary assays
pillar
the third pillar that we're going to
discuss is the orthogonal pillar and
this is where we use what we would call
an antibody independent technique to
help verify antibody dependent methods
and so the way this typically works is
you'll pull something out of a mass spec
scan
or mrna expression data and then compare
that to what you're seeing in a western
blot ihc or icc and so in this
particular example we've got cd19 uh
mrna expression data from a database
called gene visible
and you see that i've got two boxes in
the bottom left hand corner these are
boxing in the cell lines for ragi b
cells and dotty b cells and you can see
on the right we are getting very strong
and specific binding to both of these
cell lines i've got those blocks in in
red as well
and this would allow us to sort of
fulfill this orthogonal pillar during
our validation process here
the fourth pillar is the biological
characteristics pillar and this is
going to be a little bit more specific
to the biology as it relates to your
target protein
and these are more widely applicable
where we've got some sort of
phospho-specific antibody or some sort
of
protein that is expressed under certain
biological conditions unlike other
biological conditions so here in the
bottom left
i've got the induction of
phosphorylation after addition of
hydroxyurea to a cell culture line
we've got a phosphocdk1 there in that
that top window and you can see a very
strong and clear correlation
um in the presence and absence of
hydroxyurea
on the right we've got a series of ips
where we have treated
cells with topocide
and that etobicide treatment induces
phosphorylation which we can detect with
our fossil specific cap one antibody
there in the in the top corner and we
are also seeing the presence of
total cap one you can see there in the
re-blot in the bottom of that of that
window and this
you know again being able to sort of
manipulate and use this biology to
create the presence or absence of signal
in a western blot
allows us to fulfill the biological
characteristics pillar
the fifth pillar is what we would
describe as the recombinant expression
strategy and this one's a little bit
unique in that
it doesn't stand alone particularly well
but it can have a very solid additive
effect to
the validation strategy for any given
target
on the left
we are over expressing uh mass a mass b
and c mass
in a series of cell lines and you'll
notice that the
what we're trying to show here is
specificity to show that our mfa
antibody is not binding to mass b or c
mass
and you can see here in the top window
that we are seeing very specific binding
in that it is unique to map a
this can also be really helpful in a
scenario where whatever protein it is
that you're looking for it simply
doesn't express well
and so you can recombinantly express
those cells and then tag those for
example on the right here with an
anti-v5 or you can tag it with a v5 tag
and then detect it with an anti-v5
antibody and we can see staining in an
icc here on the far right or even iping
after a pull down with an anti-v5
antibody here right next to it so being
able to kind of use those tags and some
over expressing proteins to help step
into situations where the protein is
important but it's really difficult for
us to find
circumstances where those proteins are
expressing at a sufficiently high level
for
detection natively
finally here in pillar six this is what
we would refer to as the genetic
strategy
and for all intents and purposes you're
going to know this is a knockout cell
line so basically here on the left we
have recombinantly removed ubqln4s
gene from a mda mb231 cell line and we
can see a very clear distinction between
wild type and knockout cells and got
very strong signal in the wild type that
signals abrogated in the knockouts and
we can also correlate that in an icc
experiment as well you see that over
here on the right where we're getting
pretty good binding and staining in an
icc of wild type mda mv231s
where over here on the right we've got
knockout cells where that signal has
been abrogated
so again it's really important to keep
in mind that the
a single one of these pillars as a
general rule is not going to serve to
say that this is a validated product in
and of itself now
of these six the knockout genetic
strategies pillar is probably the most
capable of standing on its own but
typically we're going to kind of combine
this with a few other types of studies
and create more of a critical mass of
data that is you know very difficult to
argue with for all intents and purposes
so um
prior to purchasing anything
it's really important to keep in mind
like what what do you need this antibody
to be and this kind of harkens back to
that slide that i showed earlier with
the kind of green red gradient do you
need something specific or are you okay
using something like this block here on
the right where
you can still see your your target
protein but it's just not going to look
as pretty for some people that's all you
need for others you really need to be
able to pin down something like this
this cap one blot here over on the left
where it's a nice clean sharp target
band nothing else on there
again keep in mind the question of how
is this antibody been validated by the
manufacturer and make sure that you have
a good feel for species specificity what
applications this thing has been
validated for and what cell alliances
has been validated for and finally use
your use your scientific training like
can you look through this data and are
you confident in this validation data or
do you look at this and you're concerned
about what it is that you're seeing
finally after your purchase make sure
that you're using the manufacturer
recommendations as a guideline for how
you're utilizing this product are you
building in some other positive controls
are you sticking to their validated
species are you sticking to their
validated applications
don't be afraid to optimize this product
find the conditions that work for you
do be aware especially with polyclonal
products that as these antibodies age or
as lots change make sure that you
revalidate subsequent lots make sure
that you know what the implications of
those lot changes are how it affects
your work and ultimately what you need
to do to adjust for that
and finally again don't be afraid to
reach out to us most of the time
us antibody manufacturers all of our
colleagues in this field we like talking
about these products we we take a lot of
pride in the manufacturing and testing
of these products and frankly they're
they're fun for us to talk about
especially with with people who are
passionate about this work what we're
doing
and really want to dig into and
understand
the science behind these
bodies so
um
that's all i've got i'm happy to take
any questions
if you've noticed some of the unique
branding bethel laboratories was
purchased by fortis life sciences and if
you need to know anything or have any
further follow-up questions
about our products or validation please
visit us at bella.com